I want to use this video to kind of make
sure we intuitively and and otherwise
and understand the difference between a
Z this is Z statistic Z statistic
something I have trouble saying and a
and a T statistic T statistic so in a
lot of what we're doing in this
inferential statistics we're trying to
figure out what is the probability of
getting a certain sample mean so what
we've been doing especially when we have
a large sample size so let me just draw
a sampling distribution here so let's
say we have a sampling distribution of
the sample mean right here it has some
assumed mean value it has some assumed
mean value in some standard deviation
and what we want to do is we any results
that we get any result that we get let's
say we get some sample mean out here we
want to figure out the probability of
getting a result at least as Extreme as
this so what you can either figure out
the probability of getting a result
below this and subtract that from 1 or
just figure out this area right over
there and to do that we're essentially
we've been figuring out how many
standard deviations above the mean
we actually are the way we figure that
out is we take our we take our sample
mean we subtract from that our mean
itself we subtract from that what we
assumed the mean should be or maybe we
don't know what this is we the mean
should be and then we divide that we
divide that by the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution we divide that
by the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution this is how many
standard deviations we are above the
mean that is that distance right over
there now we usually don't know what
this is either we normally don't know
what that is either
and the central limit theorem told us
that assuming that we have a sufficient
sample size this thing right here this
thing is going to be the same thing as
the sample is going to be the same thing
as the standard deviation of our
population
the standard deviation of our population
divided by the square root of our sample
size so this thing right over here can
be rewritten can be re-written as our
sample mean minus the mean of our
sampling distribution of the sample mean
divided by this thing right here divided
by our population mean divided by the
square root of our sample size and this
is essentially our best sense of how
many standard deviations away from the
actual mean we are and this thing right
here we've learned it before is a
z-score or when we're dealing with an
actual statistic when it's derived from
the sample mean statistic we call this a
Z statistic Z statistic and then we
could look it up in a in a Z table or in
a normal distribution table to say
what's the probability of getting a
value of this Z or greater so that would
give us that probability so what's the
probability of getting that extreme of a
result now normally when we've done this
in the last few videos in the last few
videos we also don't know what the we
also do not know what the standard
deviation of the population is so in
order to approximate that in order to
approximate that we say that the z-score
is approximately or the Z statistic is
approximately going to be so let me just
write the numerator over again over we
estimate this using our sample standard
deviation we estimate it using our let
me just in a new color with using our
sample standard deviation using our
sample standard deviation and this is
okay this is okay if if our sample size
is greater than 30 or another way to
think about it is this will be normally
distributed normally distributed
normally distributed if our sample size
is greater than 30 even this
approximation will be approximately
normally distributed now if your sample
size is less than 30 especially it's a
good bit less than 30 all of a sudden
this expression will not be normally
distributed so let me rewrite the
expression over here
sample mean minus the mean of your
sampling distribution of the sample mean
divided by your sample standard
deviation over the square root of your
sample size we just said if this thing
is well over 30 or at least 30 then this
is this value right here this statistic
is going to be normally distributed if
it's not if this is small if that is
small then this is going to have a T
distribution this is going to have a T
distribution and then you're going to do
the exact same thing you did here but
now you would assume that the Bell is no
longer a normal distribution so in this
example it was normal it was normal all
of the Z's are normally distributed over
here in a t distribution and this will
actually be a normalized t-distribution
right here because we subtracted out the
mean so in a t distribution in a
normalized t-distribution you're going
to have a mean of zero and what you're
going to do is you want to figure out
the probability of getting a t-value
this at least this extreme so this is
some this is your T value you would get
and then essentially figure out the area
under the curve right over there
and so a very easy rule of thumb is
calculate this quantity either way
calculate this quality quantity either
way if if you have more than 30 samples
if your sample size is more than 30 this
is going your sample standard deviation
is going to be a good approximator
for your population standard deviation
and so this whole thing is going to be
approximately normally distributed and
so you can use a z table to figure out
the probability of getting a result at
least that extreme if your sample size
is small if your sample size is small
then this statistic this quantity this
is going to be is going to have a T
distribution and then you're going to
have to use a t table to figure out the
probability of getting a t-value at
least this extreme and we're going to
see this in an example a couple of
videos from now anyway hopefully that
helped clarify some things in your head
about when to use a Z to statistic or
when to use a T statistic